lidera la temida de red haqqani y se
ofrecen 5 millones de dólares por su
cabeza sirajuddin haqqani el nuevo
ministro del interior de afganistán es
requerido para ser interrogado por el
fbi por su presunta relación con el
atentado contra un hotel de kabul en
2008 que dejó seis muertos incluyendo a
un estadounidense la red haqqani es
responsable de varios de los mayores
ataques terroristas que ha vivido
recientemente afganistán incluido un
bombardeo frente a la embajada india en
2009 y la explosión de un camión-bomba
en 2017 según expertos la composición
del gobierno afgano corresponde con las
intenciones de su vecino pakistán ter
spain ha habido visita tras visita de
funcionarios de alto nivel paquistaníes
que han ayudado e incitado de esta
situación y claro que los paquistaníes
estuvieron detrás de esta toma militar
en afganistán
esta es una invasión paquistaní de
afganistán a través de sus
representantes los talibanes han y en
visiones cannes transcender praxis es
agua para eeuu catálogo a la red haqqani
como organización terrorista en 2012 se
estima que entre 3.000 y 12.000 personas
hacen parte de este grupo
vínculos cercanos con al qaeda